Hey chimichangas, it's Charlie. So this
is gonna be my Deapool video.
Ryan Reynolds and the studio confirmed some things about the movie this past weekend so
we have a lot to talk about, like we have an official synopsis now. Here's what it says:
Deadpool tells the origin story of former Special Forces operative turned mercenary
Wade Wilson who after being subjected to
a rogue experiment that leaves them
with accelarated healing powers,
adopts the alter ego Deadpool. Armed with
his new abilities
and a dark, twisted sense of humor, Deadpool hunts down the man who nearly
destroyed his life.
So we have a lot of things from Weapon X
that we have seen in the X-Men films so far that
they're going to weave into this
and I think, you know, some suggestions as to who the main villain's gonna be.
What I think is is that they'll use Doctor Killebrew and Ajax as the villains of the movie,
or at least Doctor Killebrew. They haven't confirmed any official villains yet.
They've only really announced like a couple of the characters including Morena Baccarin
who's playing Copycat. If you weren't already excited about Ryan Reynolds coming back
in a new Deadpool origin story then get pumped for Morena Baccarin and kicking some major ass.
Seriously, she's like the queen of the comic
book genre right now. She's on The Flash
as the Gideon computer, she's on Gotham as Leslie Thompkins,
and now she's in the X-Men universe as Copycat. Don't worry, I'm gonna do a whole
separate video about her eventually just because she's a really interesting character and
Morena Baccarin's awesome.They already confirmed that the Deadpool movie is a spin-off
from the X-Men films, the First Class films that they've been doing the last couple of years.
The time line is a little wonky because they had that post-credits scene in Days of
the Future Past, so here's my general explainer as to like how this Deadpool
movie fits in with the other X-men films
that are happening,
including Apocalypse. Just careful for spoilers from Days of Future Past,
I'm assuming you've all seen it by now but I'll
give you a second. Ok? Here we go. So forget about the teaser
at the end of that when they flashforward
to the future with Wolverine and Patrick Stewart,
just put that out of your mind. They're changing that, that still happens,
but because X-men: Apocalypse takes place in the eighties,
right after Days of Future Past, the Deadpool movie is probably gonna take place around then too.
Deadpool's origin story is all about
Weapon X
and at the end of Days of Future Past, if
you remember, William Stryker dredged
Wolverine up from the bottom of the river , well really it was Mystique,
masquerading as William Stryker.
The teaser was that William Stryker was gonna induct him into the Weapon X program.
Wolverine came before Deadpool in the Weapon X program.
The problem is is that, you know, because Mystique change the timeline,
she saved Wolverine,
pretending to be William Stryker, there's a lot of questions as to like how
he's going to get his Adamantium because
he does eventually get it.
Just assume that Weapon X still exists and at some point Wolverine
does get his Adamantium from them. The reason I don't think that they're gonna
change that, even though they changed the timeline a little bit,
is because Deadpool got his healing factor from Wolverine,
inside the Weapon X program. So Weapon X has to get their hands on Wolverine's healing factor.
In the comics Weapon X gives Wolverine his Adamantium
during the eighties, so it fits in the time line with the Days of Future Past and Apocalypse.
What I think is gonna happen is, is that we'll have the events of Apocalypse
and then the Deadpool movie will take place in the timeline right after that.
Don't ask me how Wolverine 3 is supposed to fit into this. I think that
will also occur in the timeline
after the Deadpool movie and Apocalypse. But because we don't know
anything about that story yet, just don't
worry about it.
Here's a quick explainer for Deadpool's back story in the comics, like how he got
started with Weapon X, how he got his
powers.
So funny story: Rob Liefeld is Deadpool's creater in the comic. He created him in
like the early nineties. There's a really funny story like a
funny Rob Liefled story behind it.
Rob Liefeld came up with the idea, sent it to the artist
and the artist said 'this is Deathstroke,
dude.
Seriously this is totally Deathstroke
from the DC Comics'. So they changed the
design just like a little bit
and they gave him the name Wade WIlson as a spin, as like an inside joke
on Slade Wilson aka Deathstroke. Comic book history is littered with characters
there are riffs of
other pre-existing character so this is
nothing new.
The really funny thing is is that Rob
Liefeld actually wrote
on the new #52 Deathstroke title whenever DC Comics was doing that the new #52 stuff back in 2012.
He quit that title like in the middle of the run. He's like 'I can't take anymore, this is crazy'.
There were a lot of logistical-editorial problems with the DC new #52 run, that's like a whole other story.
But I just think it's funny that Rob Liefeld kinda borrowed, "*borrowed*"
the Deatstroke character to create Deadpool and then quit a Deathstroke title he was writing, later.
The universe works in mysterious ways. We don't know a whole lot
about Wade Wilson's childhood other than he had some undiagnosed mental problems,
he was very aloof, but eventually he
became a mercenary.
During his adventures he fell in love with a woman named Vanessa Carlysle
who had not become Copycat yet, she's Copycat in the comics.
She has this really awesome powers, it's a lot like Mystique's she can shapeshift,
but it goes down to the genetic level, so she can mimic other people's powers in a way Mystique cannot.
Like I said, I'm totally gonna do another bonus video for her just because she's
really interesting and Mirena Bacarin is
amazing.
Eventually he learned he had cancer, broke ties with Vanessa Carlysle,
and join the Weapon X program. Weapon X
and Department K grew
out of the original Captain America Super-Soldier Program.
They're like a a dark, twisted future version of the Super-Soldier Program.
They got Wilson to join the program by
saying they could fix his cancer,
they gave him Wolverine's healing factor that fixed the cancer. The problem is, is
that it did not fix his underlying mental instability.
And in a very evil Genie type situation: be
careful what you wish for type stuff.
As result fo the healing factor he can't take drugs to balance himself out,
and they can't physically alter his brain to try and fix it.
Any changes they try to make to a chemical or biological,
just his body just burns off immediately. So he is stuck crazy.
There was a time later in the comics when he lost his healing factor but it
still didn't fix his brain so
is like the character is always gonna be
crazy. So while this is all going on in the
comics he'ss till Wade Wilson, he hasn't become Deadpool yet but he does have the healing factor.
He starts going on missions with Weapon X, ends up killing
one of his teammates. They boot him out of the program and send him to a facility
where they send washouts.
That is where he runs into Doctor Killebrew and his assistant Ajax,
two very, very evil people. While he's in the
facility they perform all kinda crazy
experiments on him and the other washouts.
He does end up meeting and falling in love with the cosmic entity Death,
starts trying to kill himself over and over so he can join her, which is kinda
crazy and funny at the same time.
Cut to later, he pisses off Ajax, the assistant, so much
that Ajax's messes up Wilson's friend in the program so bad
that Wilson is forced to kill him out of mercy. Ajax rips
Wilson's heart out his chest then leaves him for dead, just like dumps the body.
His healing factor re-grows
him a heart but it doesn't fix all the scars on his body
so he starts looking more like the Deadpool that you see today without the mask on.
While he was in the facility being
tested on, all the other test subjects
developed a Deadpool to bet
on who would survive the longest, like who'd go the longest about dying from the experiments.
Deadpool takes that name in vows revenge
on Ajax
and Killebrew. So that's where you get the
Deadpool name, that's where it came from.
Because this movie is telling kinda the origin story of Deadpool I think that
we're going to see a version of that play out on screen though, they'll probably gonna make
some minor changes.
I'm not expecting to see the cosmic
entity Death. I know everyone kinda wants
to see Death in the Marvel Universe
eventually,
but technically this is a X-Men film so who knows what they're gonna do with that.
They might just substitute Vanessa Carlysle for Death. Maybe Marvel can make that happen,
like Death can take Vanessa Carlysle's face. Here's my big question for you guys:
which other big Deadpool characters do
you wanna see in this movie? And
do you think that they're gonna put Death in the movie too? Fox has not done
a Shi'ar movie, they haven't done like a
space-based X-Men universe movie yet,
so they're like three steps away from doing cosmic entities.
Like I said my next Deadpool bonus video is going to be about Morena Baccarin's Copycat character,
be sure to subscribe to get that. If there are any other like special Deadpool videos
you guys wanna do let me know but
I'll try and post that sometime next week. There's like a whole bunch awesome stuff
happening in the next couple days that I
need to get out.
Here's a quick update on my video schedule for like the next day or two,
just because there's like 3 or 4 videos I'm trying to get out.
So they just confirm Hawkgirl for the Arrow/Flash spinoff, so I'm gonna do a video for
that before Flash tomorrow,
I also have the Walking Dead Q&A, don't worry I'm giving away two gift certificates in that
and I have a special Crunchyroll giveaway
that I'm gonna do, so I'll try to drop
that all tomorrow morning,
or at least all that stuff by Wednesday morning. You guys have no idea how
excited I get when all these awesome news just dumps at once all at the same time.
While you guys wait for that,  in case you haven't seen yet, you click here for my top 5 Deadpool stories
from the comics and you can click here for my Walking Dead finale video from last night.
Thank you so much watching everybody, let's high-five and go get some chimichangas.